[Music]
what is happening there rejectives we're
gonna watch ourselves the witcher vote
mayor episode seven of season two this
pen ultimate i think so yeah finally
seven of eight god can't wait for this
crap show to be over so we can wait for
season three guys hit that like button
if you've made it this far in the video
we've earned it also subscribe and click
that notification bell get notified when
our reaction for the finale of this is
up full length watch logs as always or
write our patreon page major thank you
to all become superjects by checking all
our content over there your support
means a lot and lastly thank you to the
boys at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights you know what a lot of
people don't think the people who uh
help them edit down stuff sometimes and
i like to uh pride us on it instead of
putting the spotlight on them i want to
put the spotlight on us
for making sure to thank them oh yeah i
mean we're we're really good at that how
much work it takes for for us to get out
of the way just mention that deserve a
pat on the back for that i do yeah so
well done dude like i just feel like i
deserve the credit pinnacle of this
community right now
those editors are lucky to have you they
are
and i could just find anyone else
[Music]
i need to find her
you need to let me take care of your
wounds
oh
do you believe
jennifer means to harm the girl
i wish jennifer knew of the parents you
spoke of but i learned my lesson about
jennifer and wishes
we assume the worst
because we fear to hope
that's how i feel every time i upload a
video
attest to that if nilfgaard's got him if
they'll hold him to lure you there
their nearest outpost
syndra no no i fantasized about going
back finding the black knight
and shoving my sword through his throat
until his feathers are soaked in blood
it's crazy how she doesn't suspect
yennefer at all i know
carol trusts her we must go to sintra
together
we must hurry
that's right
it's kind of goofy
chaos will be yours
there's a little
wicked witchy
just a tad campy i don't want to burden
you
a new position of authority doesn't
change the fact
that i love you was this established
earlier
it's kind of new to me
if it was it was subtle or i miss him
half of the elves did not muster for
training this morning the celebration of
the child's birth went late into the
night i will talk to them you
are not that commander but she is their
leader
there's a difference
if the elves refuse to serve let me deal
with them
the generals will respect a strong hand
oh it's like you want that to happen you
want that to happen
i was looking for food i'm no spy
are you going to do it
for [ __ ] sake
[Music]
your harmonies were a little pitchy
gordon
you're amazing talent recognizes talent
let's go again three four and look yeah
good sir you would not know talent if i
shoved it up here girl
[ __ ] it
i need your help
fine
he's your protector
he's a father i never had
daddy
what was between you and gerald
misunderstandings
regret
hope
and fear
you love him too
everyone loves geralt how can you not
you thought he's like a cat you gotta
work to earn his affection i trust
you're unaware that your fighters failed
to show this morning i heard well then i
trust
you'll make sure it never happens again
many of us have had a change of heart
well then you change it back oh i must
ask
are these your words or cahirs
i value the bond we have
but family that's the only bond that
can't be broken and that's the one i
must protect awkward we are now
frenemies
she was on the run she'd lost her magic
she lost her magic yeah i know it was
great
look when the radiant guards grabbed her
she nutted something about
forests and
mothers and
huts
she's in league was a deathless mother
well she sounds like a hoot
who left me as a demon that feeds on
pain
uh-oh
we need to go to centra
whoa what's in centra
oh
yeah i knew it i knew it i was like at
the dwarfs yeah so the reunion episode
remember my men oh of course good to see
you all again
i have absolutely no recollection of any
of these people
i just say that right in front of him
i'm not my usual type
but you'll do roach four
but going on an adventure
what a good thing they just stumbled
across
team and horse
super easy barely an inconvenience
all right siri time to magic up a bridge
lesson number two
let's see what your chaos can do
don't strain trust your power to do the
work
[Music]
your eyes are bleeding oh
yeah
siri stop
stop
[Laughter]
cool [ __ ] magic
i'm so sorry i don't know what happened
when you have power like this
never apologize by the way your eyes are
bleeding yeah just don't look in a
mirror any time soon i saw sarah left
center at sudden they were looking for
you jennifer yes
they believed she was dead oh i had a
chance to clarify for him but i never
did
if what she says is true this child
has the potential to
end all war and start a new one
wreck the whole earth in the process i
will not continue to put my girls at
risk unnecessarily i wouldn't ask you to
if it wasn't necessary
she's so much more vulnerable this time
around
look i'm sorry
calm down
i have always
considered you my equal partner even
though you get paid half as much as me
i brought in the elves to fight for us
but they
have had a change of heart
you're my blood
blood is a pod that can't be broken
i think i've heard that before there are
those who are obsessed with finding
power and are those who know their place
you know which one you are thank gods um
you wouldn't have come back here if you
didn't he would be about to leave
are we ever going to have a full-on war
with nilfgaard you know it's
two seasons
from here or now i want to focus on
keeping that elven hope alive
tell theextra i'm done
you just signed your death contract
we're supposed to be on the same side
searching for princess cirilla as soon
as we unload frangilla's dead weight if
we don't all our heads will be on the
top
professor xavier
i have
so much resentment for my attitudes and
training that
i forget
and where else could i have learnt the
paralytic qualities of nightshade my
most valuable lesson though
given my last night there creepy when
yennefer
wengerberg
stole the seat of aiden to which i was
entitled caleb
told me
when everyone doesn't like trust me
[Music]
cool oh man she's doing like the logan
thing yeah you must do
whatever
it's required
love it
to what you've earned
oh
so when he arrives tomorrow
awesome
are you sure that guy's dead though the
one with the eye he might have just lost
it out yeah
tomorrow madder than ever
yeah freaking eye patch and all you
never even wanted this child in the
first place and now now it's like she
has turned your entire world upside down
what i'm really asking you is why
couldn't i have been their child
and what about jennifer she's hurt siri
like now you just have to kill her look
people do stupid things when they think
they're trapped in a corner go well
that's what friends do
they come back
this is different there's gonna be a
tower jaws out here
i'll be in a prison cell singing
somewhere to mice
how could it look the same
everyone i've known is gone
what's going on with the monoliths and
the monsters and all that yeah that
chernobug just flew off that last
episode
when you had magic you controlled the
chaos but it controls me
no one's been able to teach me how to
use it i mean your two lessons have gone
pretty well
yeah the lessons are repeat this yeah
say what i said and be magic
you still have time to turn back it's
not too late
and you
for me it is like chaos
i thought i had to
[Music]
wow
i need to get him
he's not here
he never was no shaking to believe you
yeah i was stupid
and i was selfish
you have to come with me oh
why would you yeah i don't trust you
oh great
hey
how's about we break another monolith
shall we
no you gotta get the [ __ ] out of there
now
siri time to yell yeah scream
scream [ __ ] really loud we gotta fight
out
oh whoa
nice catch
hey protector oh
here we go
hold them
how could you do this
i'm so sorry she had to change her heart
at the last minute give her a break yeah
she did the thing she's better for the
doubt man say it turn you back to the
forest that hurt oh god damn girl turn
your front to me
this show does hate babies
oh god this show hates babies
oh cool
nice
oh that's neat
oh
she's being set free
she shouldn't be able to escape
unless she's had her fill
of pain and desperation shouldn't have
left siri
[Music]
really shouldn't have left siri yep
and it's begun
[Music]
so all he has to do is kill siri
yeah yeah and then we can move on
he's fine i think she's holding the show
back seriously from um yeah
really taking off that direction it
could go it could be a better show i'm
just saying man we could have a monster
sleigh of the week but instead we got
searing
all right all right let's talk about
look guys i'm john
oh hey oh welcome
john you look even better than i do you
look at vilga forts right now
sexy ass made you
what's up vilga ford
you know he's uh he's the elf guy who
just lost his kid just kidding that's
phil evandro
whose name i finally have committed to
memory
every time he shows up i'm like okay as
soon as they say his name i'll
committing it to memory seven episodes
later got it he's the elf that i feel
like i should care more about but i just
i just don't you see elf you think is
gonna be awesome at some point and for
the most part it's just kind of there
he's in season one he's a nightmare of
the wolf he's
important here but i'm like i just don't
yeah he's not that interesting to me
he's just kind of
it's kind of a pushover in a lot of ways
yeah
yeah so yeah this was good it was a
little bit some of this this one felt a
little uh
i'm not sure what it was about this one
i like the last half a lot and there are
isolated moments in the first half that
i quite enjoyed
i'm just kind of um
this kepler felt like we were watching
like a lot of setup and i'm like is this
season gonna conclude at all or are we
just setting up more of what's to come
the entire war is taking place next
episode as well as all of series final
transformation well i don't even know
what it is to really expect because you
you got bald-headed buff patrick stewart
uh you know whatever
whatever yeah
the one that um
dara was spying for yeah so you have
him you know i'm not i'm just gonna call
people by their descriptions i'll let
john handle the names so yeah like dara
who's uh yeah spying and he got that and
he's like yeah we got to reclaim sintra
i was kind of unaware there were people
still in the center
those are not guard warriors right yeah
yeah yeah that because it took over uh
so i didn't realize like oh there are
people like watching the land that are
not guard they have taken over yeah that
makes sense so when she did put the hole
in the ground like oh yeah that lines up
i just kind of forgot about that for i
thought it was kind of forsaken for a
while yeah
and um
yeah but then then you have like of
course the deathless mother uh
looks like they i feel like they're
setting up for yennefer like that's my
main takeaway with most of this is
i feel like they're setting up i feel
like they're setting up i feel like
they're setting up and usually when i
talk about an episode i'm kind of
talking about the
the immediacy of the scenes that we're
at on display like there's a few scenes
that i think are highlights
like fringilla murdering the people at
the table
a really cool visually realized scene
very professor x logan
um but the motive behind it you know
because she doesn't can't go anywhere
like she's losing the elves
the elves are like we have one baby
everything does everything yeah forget
the wall all of us are going to just be
this baby's family yeah
every single elf forget our political
life again at all
and then you know like the nilfgaard
people don't respect her and
then she goes to her uncle who's like me
and no one respects you and i don't so
then um you know like they're building
up the white flame essentially the
emperor of the evilness and
you know so i think her motive behind
you know you're gonna spin this story
and you're gonna tell them like i had to
do what i had to do and it was a badass
thing that i did what i did but i still
serve you you know that was a that was a
good moment like that to me was a great
immediate scene or
um
the
the moment yennefer and
siri when
you know they they lock
telepathic ways of talking to each other
yeah yeah something that they could
easily just have done with their voices
but uh you know they're excited to do it
in a cooler fast to make sure you know
they're not just talking they're having
a mind moment yeah i really like that uh
i like that moment a lot too uh and
especially like yennefer coming i really
believe that it's as much as [ __ ]
predictable as it was that jennifer it
was so it was already predictable
without yaskir having to be like she
must change him on goats yeah yeah you
don't need to set me up for that
of course she will and
you know like so then she that that
whole scene too i thought was really
well acted and series acting too but it
does mainly felt really just felt like
they were setting up so many things
that some of the actual immediate scenes
do you know where i'm i'm going with
that
and then you got like fire [ __ ] and
that only was one one
like there's just so many different
scenes yeah that are we just are we
already planting the seeds for season
three because how could you possibly
like wrap up
this storyline you're telling in one
episode in the finale i'm not expecting
a big battle or something and nor do i
expect them to wrap up everything it
just feels like it's
feels as for a season that's felt
remarkably focused i suddenly started
feeling like it's losing focus it feels
in these last couple of episodes like
it's become very scatter shot and like
there's a whole bunch of threads and
yeah they're all like building to
something but i feel like earlier on
there was a better balance of setups and
payoffs and things where it's like the
first season you knew it was going to
continue but i don't know it still had
like a finality or
it felt like yeah one contained unit
uh that could lead to the next unit
and uh
yeah i'm very curious to see where it
ends up because right now i i would
agree it's like there's a lot i'm still
enjoying and i really like the
characters but it doesn't feel quite as
focused or finessed either because you
know with as with more going on and more
scenes to cut to it feels like we're
spending
less time with more characters
almost yeah no dude there's a gazillion
characters yes this is like there's like
the check-in episode yeah yeah it's
funny because even in this season it
didn't always feel that way and it's
that and in the last episode i always
said this and and you know like i said
i'm still very much enjoying the show
overall but these two episodes uh this
and the last one have felt a lot more
like a tv show
than uh you know just kind of the epic
story that it's felt like up until this
point and
yeah there there is
a certain sense of maybe maybe
everything's just like a lot more just
sort of immediately plot based right now
or something because i feel like there
are less of those in between and quiet
moments of character reflection or
character just tonality that you might
have gotten beforehand no it felt like
there's you know this fantasy stories
often have
almost a like shakespearean quality to
the way they handle their drama
you know it's it is very accentuated
like that
uh but there was moments here where i
felt like i was watching a soap opera
but
like with like this i i don't know i
apparently missed all the clues
about to say uh and
one of the few ethnic guys
yeah yeah
then hooking up with each other
that's what you're saying
yeah them sexy like that them hooking up
with each other
and
um you know like i love you i'm like oh
i i didn't i didn't realize we were that
far away like i didn't realize you guys
were hooking up maybe i didn't realize
you were that involved to to that point
and
i'm i'm not that interested invested in
him to the point where i'm like whoa
yeah
but yeah like the way they handle that
whole scene with josiah uh tris i mean
when he comes in yeah
it's like watching some weird
soap opera play yeah
uh just like comes walking in from the
background and like you're to haircut
there's conflict yeah you're going to
tell them everything now i'm fighting
to say yeah we're yelling at each other
yeah trust you've got to leave
you've got to storm off and yeah we're
going to have a dramatic back and forth
the best scenes i thought were with
actually the main the main four uh of
this of which were jazz gear yeah and um
like i love them being reunited together
and i think their chemistry is still
great i like how you can see the
trajectory of geralt's growth by how
he's a little more vulnerable with him
you know saying right up front like i
missed you he starts to cry he cowers in
a corner hits his dick
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah he gets a tattoo of yesterday
yeah just to prove how sorry he is
drinking his sorrows away it's really
carried away like i've seen a lot asked
him to sing the whole time
so that was a good scene and i liked
like those scenes of them together are
great
and um
uh everything with the
yennefer and
um
siri was a good
some timing plot convenience stuff i do
think it's funny how like i get the
series [ __ ] the god
but at the same time it's like just say
this
yeah
it's still a convenience store look at
me
so much of the part where she just gets
mad and teleports you know yeah and it's
it was i know i understand that it's
part of the emotionality of the
character but at the same time i was
like your training seems to be going
just fine it's just that you haven't
been able to like slow down and have
like a concentrated study
you know you haven't had time to study
like a normal person but every time you
have to dip into your chaos it seems to
work i mean you're trying to sword fight
you're trying to become a witcher yeah
you're doing it which everything you
want and you're pretty good at most of
them like just give yourself a chance
yeah yeah yeah that's a great call um
and i mean there is two it is kind of
the timing of the dwarves too sorry yeah
no rules like the convenience of that
i'm like all right yeah hey there they
are they're they throw my axe in here
well it's that it's it's timing of
things like that and also it's and maybe
it's not uh you know out of the
maybe the geography lines up but it's
also falling into that place where i'm
like wait a minute how far are any of
these things from anywhere because
unless characters are portaling it seems
like anybody can get anywhere in the
nick of time because so many things
happened in this episode in the nick of
time
yeah of like characters arriving yeah
we're just right where they need to be
and if they hadn't what would happen
yeah let's reiterate here guys
strong positives for everyone thinks all
we do is complain yeah things we've
already pointed out
main cast good gerald and yaskier crude
i like you ask your new song i'll have
that not to listen to when you're the
person i'm like i gotta download that
that's great his sexy body shots sexy
body shots apparently ascii is pretty
cut he's very good jennifer and um
syria
frangilla
killing killing people killing those
fools yeah great scene the way they
realize the deathless mother as this
like malevolent threat
that you know i see i think they should
have established that a little bit
earlier instead of just revealing it
here in this you know season like they
just talk about that and whenever the
wolf am i do they i don't remember this
mother i don't remember her as much like
imprisoning her i don't remember if they
do
not but the show shouldn't require that
you watch
your animated movie you know you know
and that's something i think that they
should have like set up earlier because
they would have made the looming threat
of that more weight as opposed to
geralt's just revealing it right now and
oh that's a threat you know it's like
that things will just hold more weight
and it becomes a little bit um
here's how i've been feeling about this
episode in particular is that the first
season felt like it was based off of a
book that i really had to pay attention
to yeah this feels like they really
movied up a novel yes
yeah yeah yeah no i think you'd i think
you're right yeah and uh and i like a
lot of it obviously it's just it's more
about like tonality atmosphere execution
because they have the convenience of
getting the central other so you're
getting at like yeah i mean it's a cool
movie moment and i was happy about it
well and even the lie working out so
that girl like you know it has no
bearing on but her even lying and being
like gary's probably already in cintra
and then sure enough he still shows up
there yeah they still find completely
unrelated reasons to go to the same
place which in some breaths
there are aspects of that i like and
there are aspects of that where i'm like
convenient all right
yeah you know because what
it's one of those episodes i think begs
you to start asking well what
if they hadn't made it in time for this
or that what would happen you know well
yeah it's like there's just this this
episode is the timing episode yeah
of course like it's like
the freaking dwarves
yep um just in the nick of time for for
uh
and they have to have a horse
the horse yeah the yennefer with the
the types of regret what she's about to
do yeah to change her mind
like of course she should read it
moments before this show mostly i have
to change your heart right in time to
having a misunderstanding they go to the
deathless mother right when she leaves
yeah you know she's been locked here
forever and now after all these series
of events and so i just think there's
there are things
about this particular episode where i'm
like it's really well shot
the acting is still as grand as ever um
and they're really good at realizing
things like chaos like the magic the way
they visually capture that makes it feel
chaotic which is true true yeah so still
and i think like even the depthless
mother with the
leg like really in the house is is a
sentient type of supernatural force yeah
was really cool like i love the imagery
of that it felt like i was some folklore
pages of something i might have read
when i was a kid
you know um because i read a lot of
[ __ ] up things and so that's what i
thought it might have been i was i
really liked that a lot
so yeah there's a there's a lot here and
i'm excited like jennifer and and
geralt's back together and yaski are
back in the photo you know yeah these
are these are all really good things um
so we'll see we'll see yeah it goes i
hope i don't really care about the elves
i care about the elves purpose and cause
and i feel bad for them but i don't
really care about any of the characters
i want to i want to actually i don't
care i don't i almost get there every
time and then there's just not as much
as i hope there could be and i mean you
know the dwarves the elves they're not
really either featured
but in their two small appearances i
feel like we've had
more sort of connective time with the
dwarfs yeah which i understand have been
changed pretty pretty well from the
original stories anyway but yeah like i
i always feel like ah man
whenever we cut to the albums we're
mostly just dealing with fragility here
and i like frangilla and to an extent i
like i like to hear way more when he was
fugitive with the beard uh but yeah
there are things in here that i that i
want yeah like you said i want to be
invested in and i mean i think
it's funny because like they're all the
threads and hints here like going back
to the deathless mother thing it's like
i loved the intro of that because it was
like okay this seems sinister but also
maybe beneficial i can't tell i wasn't
expecting her i guess they didn't build
up properly that the deathless mother
would be the ultimate threat for the
whole season because it's kind of how
they've treated this ending point i was
like i thought it was just a problem for
the immediate situation at hand for
yennefer yeah
and um or like each of them in an
isolated way has their own problem with
the deathless mother but not that like
this is the linchpin that all of the
yeah are connected to and i figure like
they could have done like they cut to
her and they do
a version of it but i feel like they
could have done something more effective
over the course of the season to really
make you be like oh god what is this
deathless mother thing going to pay off
into yeah that's what i meant by and i
don't know maybe that just falls on us
for but for not
picking up on that well
it's i mean it's been there like they do
flashes and cuts and stuff but that's
all i felt like is just sort of just
feel like it was just contained to like
certain character motives not really as
the
you know it's like at least in like the
first season it's really simple like
nilfgaard's coming
yeah like that's the threat and it's
like the details are there in the mix of
when you shuffle around characters and
reasonings to get involved in the fight
and and all that and here i'm like
okay so like everyone's after siri
but
you know and and then i'm like what are
they doing i feel like for a show that's
already
so compact with
like like really so much lower yeah i am
like i think you guys might be doing a
little too much right now yeah
because there's so much because all
right i guess it's about everyone's
trying to get to siri
and uh you know and and then
now it's like okay the deathless mothers
would attach yourself to siri right
that's what it is that's what happened
and
and is that the thing that would act
because i thought siri was a threat
enough as it is on her own and that's
kind of been the worry
is that she would go all daenerys
targaryen yeah
wanda from house of m or dark phoenix
you know like i thought that was the
main concern
and now it seems like the main threat is
siri deathless mother hybrid yeah
it's more it seems like it's almost more
okay what's the threat
the different combinations of who gets
siri rather than just siri and her
untapped power herself yeah i'm like
okay i'll probably click better by the
time we uh get to
but by the time we watch uh the fight
my hope is that like all this i'm saying
is just like kind of washed away
by the time we watch the finale yeah and
then i'm like okay all right oh that's
better yeah yeah he's gotta take it as a
whole yeah for sure yeah
and sometimes hey there's a lot going on
right before the big finale you know it
doesn't like most of you guys we watch
this one episode at a time where most of
you who watch the show
watch it like in chunks of like three to
four episodes at a time or a whole
season at once which i don't know why
you would do that now that's that's
exhausting exhausting
how much good focus
how many how many emotional beats and
details are really taking it it says so
much but hey uh thanks for being here
and i'll see you for the finale next
week see you guys
[Music]